This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. We live in a post-billionaire's world. There was an age of billions and it has been over for so long. Most of us have no idea how huge billions once was. 100 years ago, there were 830 pool halls in my city of Chicago. Now if you add up all the gas stations, all the McDonald's and all the Starbucks in Chicago right now, you'd be nowhere close to that number. You'd be a little under 600 if you want to be exact. And I know you do, you beautiful nerds. Today, Chicago has fewer than 10 pool halls.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我们生活在一个后亿万富翁时代。曾经有一个亿万富翁的时代，但它早已结束。我们大多数人根本不知道“亿万”曾经有多么巨大。100年前，在我的城市芝加哥有830家台球厅。现在，如果你把芝加哥所有的加油站、麦当劳和星巴克加起来，也远达不到那个数字。准确地说，还不到600家。我知道你们这些可爱的书呆子肯定想知道确切数字。今天，芝加哥剩下的台球厅不到10家。
That is Dan Weissman, reporter, Chicagoan, Dan originally reported the story for Marketplace. So billiards. Not what it used to be. But this is a post-billards world in a much more profound sense, because the growth of billiards led to the development of a material that, for better or worse, came to define the modern world. I just want to say one word to you. Just one word.
那是丹·韦斯曼，记者，芝加哥人，丹最初为《市场》节目报道了这个故事。所以，台球。它已经不是以前的样子了。但这是一个更深层意义上的“后台球”世界，因为台球的发展导致了一种材料的开发，无论好坏，它定义了现代世界。我只想对你说一个词。就一个词。
You listening? Plastics. This story starts with a guy named Michael Phalen, who's regarded by everybody as the really the father of American Billiards. That's Michael Shamus. He's the author of the illustrated encyclopedia of Billiards. Phalen was a brilliant player, but he also raised awareness of the sport, promoted it, arranging the biggest big money matches. Phalan was totally remarkable, because he was everything. He was an all around everything guy. He started a huge billiards hall in San Francisco.
你在听吗？塑料。这个故事始于一个叫迈克尔·费伦的人，他被所有人视为美国台球之父。那是迈克尔·谢默斯。他是《台球插图百科全书》的作者。费伦不仅是一位出色的球员，他还提高了人们对这项运动的认识，推广了它，并安排了当时最大的高额奖金比赛。费伦非常了不起，因为他无所不能。他是一个全能型的人。他在旧金山开了一家巨大的台球厅。
He patented a new kind of billiard cushion, and then he took the money he had won, playing billiards and writing books on billiards, and used it to become the first big manufacturer of billiard tables and equipment. Phalan created the age of billiards in the US, and he felt that to further popularize the game of billiards. And some more tickets to matches, and some more books, and some more equipment, he would need to standardize the gear. Because if tables and balls weren't the same from one location to another, well, you were basically playing a different game every time you went somewhere new.
他为一种新型台球桌垫申请了专利，然后用他打台球和写台球书赚来的钱，成为了第一家大型台球桌和设备制造商。费伦在美国创造了台球时代，他觉得为了进一步普及台球游戏，卖出更多的比赛门票、更多的书和更多的设备，他需要标准化装备。因为如果桌子和球在不同地方不一样，那么你每次去新地方玩的时候，基本上就是在玩一种不同的游戏。
But standardizing the billier ball was no easy task. It's a very, very high standard to meet. The billier ball has to have certain physical properties. It has to rebound properly. It has to be a uniform density. And at the time, there was really only one material that would do, ivory, which was not cheap. Going to Africa, shooting elephants,
但是标准化台球并不是一件容易的事。这是一个非常、非常高的标准。台球必须具备某些物理特性。它必须能正确反弹。它必须具有均匀的密度。而在当时，真的只有一种材料可以胜任，那就是象牙，而且价格不菲。去非洲猎杀大象，
that is dangerous and expensive. Not to mention horrible. And people for decades had been trying to find substitutes for ivory. And they tried a variety of materials, including even metal balls, iron balls, which really don't perform well. Iron billiard balls just weren't the same.
那既危险又昂贵。更不用说太可怕了。几十年来，人们一直试图寻找象牙的替代品。他们尝试了各种材料，甚至包括金属球、铁球，但它们的表现真的不好。铁制台球就是不一样。
Ivory balls had just the right weight, the most even roll, the best rebound of the custick, of each other, of the side of the table. Nothing was as good. And not only that, only the best grade ivory would do. In fact, when you look at records from the ivory trade, the top grade of ivory is actually called billiard ball ivory.
象牙球有着恰到好处的重量，最均匀的滚动，以及与球杆、其他球和台边碰撞时最好的反弹效果。没有什么比它更好。不仅如此，只有最优质的象牙才行。事实上，当你查看象牙贸易记录时，顶级象牙实际上被称为“台球级象牙”。
And billiard balls required a lot of billiard ball grade ivory. Unlike the ivory on piano keys, which were just a veneer over wood, billiard balls had to be made of 100% solid ivory. And therefore, the average number of billiard balls that could be obtained from a single tusk was three. If you are the best luckiest billiard ball trainer,
台球需要大量的台球级象牙。不像钢琴键上的象牙只是木头上的贴面，台球必须由100%实心象牙制成。因此，平均从一根象牙中能得到的台球数量是三个。如果你是最好运的台球训练师，
maybe you could get five balls from one tusk, but even so, that means one set of billiard balls is gonna require killing at least two elephants. So billiard balls were very expensive. And when you're trying to build an industry, that's a problem. For Phalan's company, it was the problem. The entire trade depended on the shortage of its one exotic material. That's Robert Fredell, a professor at the University of Maryland. He
也许你能从一根象牙中得到五个球，但即便如此，这意味着一套台球需要杀死至少两头大象。所以台球非常昂贵。当你试图建立一个行业时，这就是个问题。对于费伦的公司来说，这就是问题所在。整个贸易都依赖于这种稀有材料的短缺。那是马里兰大学的教授罗伯特·弗雷德尔。他
studies the history of technology and he wrote the book on what happens next. Phalan and his colleagues were acutely aware that their dependency on ivory was not ideal. They're really desperate, I don't think it's too strong a word, to find some kind of substitute material. But if there simply wasn't anything. Failing takes out an ad in the paper, and here's a dramatization of what happened when a guy named John Wesley Hyatt found that ad.
研究技术史，他写了一本关于接下来发生什么的书。费伦和他的同事们敏锐地意识到，他们对象牙的依赖并不理想。他们真的很绝望，我觉得用这个词并不夸张，想要找到某种替代材料。但当时根本就没有什么东西。费伦在报纸上登了一则广告，下面是当一个叫约翰·卫斯理·海厄特的人看到那则广告时发生的事情的戏剧化演绎。
Say John, look at this, read it yourself. A prize of $10,000 for the discovery of a satisfactory substitute for ivory and making billiard balls. That's from a 1937 episode of a radio show called Cavalcade of America. Say, that's a lot of money. So it is. In terms of wages people earned at the time, it was like $3 million.
“听着，约翰，看看这个，你自己读读。”“悬赏10,000美元，寻找一种令人满意的象牙替代品来制造台球。”这是1937年一档名为《美国巡礼》的广播节目中的片段。“天哪，那可是一大笔钱。”“确实如此。以当时人们的工资水平来看，相当于现在的300万美元。”
Hi, it wasn't a chemist, but he was a tinkerer and he worked for years to win failing's prize. By trade, Hi, it was a printer. And printers use nitrated cellulose to protect their hands. It's still sold as liquid bandages. And that material turned out to have very interesting properties, and in particular it dissolved, and it creates a very sure-up reliquate. In the radio dramatization, Hayek gets his key inspiration when a bottle of
海厄特不是化学家，但他是个修补匠，他花了多年时间试图赢得费伦的奖金。海厄特原本是一名印刷工。印刷工使用硝化纤维来保护双手。它现在仍作为液体绷带出售。事实证明，这种材料具有非常有趣的特性，特别是它溶解后会产生一种非常粘稠的液体。在广播剧中，海厄特在看到一瓶
the stuff overturns, and he watches it dry into a film that he finds interesting. Why this bit of film has given me an idea, and the idea it might be worth $10,000. Hi I need to say you're going to heat that light-created cotton and compress it. That's right. I'm going to hear it. As far away as I can before I start using that press. But John Hyatt and his lab assistant Jim kept going. They'd heat up the nitrated cotton, put it in the press, and... Ready to open the press, John? Yeah. Throw the lever. John, what is it?
这种东西被打翻时获得了灵感，他看着它干涸成一层他觉得有趣的薄膜。“为什么这片薄膜给了我一个主意，这个主意可能值10,000美元。”“海厄特，我需要你说你要加热那种硝化棉并压缩它。”“没错。我要加热它。在我开始使用那个压机之前，离它越远越好。”但约翰·海厄特和他的实验室助手吉姆继续尝试。他们加热硝化棉，把它放进压机里，然后……“准备好打开压机了吗，约翰？”“是的。拉动杠杆。约翰，那是什么？”
Why don't you speak? What's the matter? Look, Jim. And then the press. Look at it. Jim, it's what we've been trying to find all this time. And the material that would take the place of ivory was plastic. Hi it called his new material, Celluloid, but Celluloid did not win, fail in his $10,000 prize. Celluloid is a wonderful material.
“你为什么不说话？怎么了？”“看，吉姆。还有压机里。看它。吉姆，这就是我们一直试图寻找的东西。”而这种可以取代象牙的材料就是塑料。海厄特把他这种新材料称为“赛璐珞”，但赛璐珞并没有赢得费伦的10,000美元奖金。赛璐珞是一种很棒的材料。
It's a beautiful plastic. It can be colored in all sorts of ways. It can be shaped beautifully. It has a wonderful range of uses. But, billiard ball, if it's not one of them. Balls made a celluloid just didn't bounce right, but Hayet tried to make a go of it anyway. He does set up a billiard ball company,
它是一种美丽的塑料。它可以以各种方式着色。它可以被塑造得很漂亮。它有广泛的用途。但是，台球并不是其中之一。用赛璐珞做的球弹跳效果不好，但海厄特还是尝试去做了。他确实成立了一家台球公司，
but his ball of or not made him sayolite. They have a thin veneer of sayolite on the outside, but they're mainly plaster on the inside and they're very inferior by your ball. Hyatt didn't give up on sayolite. He went into business with his brother, Isaiah. The Hyatt's set up a whole series of companies to try to exploit what they are convinced is a very nifty material, but they can't figure out what on earth the market's going to be. They tried dental plates. You can color so you Lloyd to look just like real gums,
但他的球并不是用赛璐珞做的。它们外面有一层薄薄的赛璐珞，但里面主要是石膏，作为台球来说质量非常差。海厄特并没有放弃赛璐珞。他与他的兄弟以赛亚合伙做生意。海厄特兄弟成立了一系列公司，试图利用他们确信是一种非常灵巧的材料，但他们无法弄清楚市场到底在哪里。他们尝试过假牙托。你可以把赛璐珞染成看起来像真牙龈的样子，
but there's a problem. Turns out that shall you like get soft if you drink any hot tea. Eventually they find the best use for celluloid is imitation ivory. I'll be it, not for billiard balls, but for versions of popular ivory luxury goods. Nice handles, combs, hand mirrors, even toys and boxes, a gigantic range of things,
但有一个问题。事实证明，如果你喝热茶，赛璐珞会变软。最终他们发现赛璐珞最好的用途是仿象牙。虽然不是用于台球，而是用于各种流行的象牙奢侈品。精美的把手、梳子、手镜，甚至玩具和盒子，种类繁多，
many of which would never actually have been made at Ivory. Also, piano keys. A Sears catalog from the 1890s offers pianos with a choice of key coverings. Ivory or Celluloid. And of course, the most famous use of Celluloid would eventually be to make film stock for movies. Meanwhile, billiard balls kept getting made out of Ivory.
其中许多原本根本不会用象牙制造。还有钢琴键。1890年代的西尔斯目录提供了带有不同琴键覆盖物的钢琴。象牙或赛璐珞。当然，赛璐珞最著名的用途最终是制造电影胶片。与此同时，台球仍然是用象牙制造的。
Ivory that came mostly from Africa, which of course the Europeans had been busy colonizing and exploiting, and the ivory trade was pretty awful for the people of Africa. Joseph Conrad wrote Heart of Darkness based largely on his own experience in the Belgian Congo, where ivory was the big product. Conrad called the whole enterprise, quote, the vileist scramble for loot that ever disfigured the history of human conscience. And Conrad didn't necessarily care about this part, but obviously the ivory trade was also terrible for elephants. So what Wajim thought a pretty common animal in Central Africa
象牙主要来自非洲，当然，欧洲人一直在忙于殖民和剥削非洲，而象牙贸易对非洲人民来说非常糟糕。约瑟夫·康拉德写的《黑暗之心》很大程度上基于他在比属刚果的亲身经历，那里象牙是主要产品。康拉德称整个事业为“人类历史上最卑劣的掠夺”。康拉德不一定关心这一部分，但显然象牙贸易对大象来说也是可怕的。所以，在19世纪中叶，在非洲中部相当常见的动物，
in the middle of the 19th century is becoming increasingly scarce by the 20th. By the time of World War I, the ivory supply crunch, the one that Michael Falon had started worrying about 50 years before had arrived. And around this time, the real significance of Hyatt's celluloid had begun to show itself. It hadn't worked for billiard balls. However, it began to inspire people to think about what artificial material might be available, what people could make, what people could invent. In 1907, a chemist named Leo Beklund comes up with a new kind of plastic made from petroleum. He names it Beklund.
到了20世纪却变得越来越稀少。到第一次世界大战时，象牙供应危机，也就是迈克尔·费伦50年前开始担心的那个危机，已经到来了。大约在这个时候，海厄特赛璐珞的真正意义开始显现。它虽然没能用于台球，但它开始启发人们思考什么人造材料是可用的，人们可以制造什么，人们可以发明什么。1907年，一位名叫利奥·贝克兰的化学家发明了一种由石油制成的新型塑料。他以自己的名字命名为“贝克兰”。
After himself. And one cool thing about bake light, you can melt it, mix in fillers. And it turns out that with that capability, you can vary the density, you can vary the elasticity, and you can make a perfect bay of ball. And so they finally replaced ivory balls with this new plastic bake Bakelite. By the 1940s, even top pool tournaments were being played with plastic balls, but by then, pool had passed its peak. It crashed as the depression began, and never regained its former prominence. The age of billiards was over.
以他自己命名。贝克兰的一个酷点是，你可以熔化它，混入填充物。事实证明，有了这种能力，你可以改变密度，改变弹性，你可以制造出一个完美的台球。所以他们最终用这种新塑料“贝克兰”取代了象牙球。到了1940年代，即使是顶级台球锦标赛也开始使用塑料球，但到那时，台球已经过了它的巅峰期。随着大萧条的开始，它崩溃了，再也没有恢复往日的辉煌。台球时代结束了。
And this post-billionards age, the age of plastics, had really gotten into gear. For example, the handle of your toothbrush is probably plastic. So undoubtedly, or the barrel of your fountain pen, the instrument panel in your car, and yet these are just a few of more than 25,000 modern uses for plastics. That's a plastics plural. By that time, you got a bunch on the market. PVC, vinyl, polyethylene, plexiglass, nylon, and in labs. They're discovering the stuff that would end up becoming teflon and saran wrap. In good old celluloid, the plastic that started it all had been retired, even from the movies.
而这个“后台球时代”，即塑料时代，已经真正启动了。例如，你的牙刷柄很可能是塑料的。毫无疑问，你的钢笔笔杆、汽车仪表盘也是，然而这些只是塑料25,000多种现代用途中的一小部分。那是“塑料”复数。到那时，市场上已经有很多种了。PVC、乙烯基、聚乙烯、有机玻璃、尼龙，在实验室里，他们正在发现最终会变成特氟龙和保鲜膜的东西。而老牌的赛璐珞，这种开启了一切的塑料，甚至在电影界也被淘汰了。
It was indispensable to the beginning of motion pictures, but it was highly dangerous and framable. Celluloid film caused several disastrous and fatal fires in movie theaters. By 1934, a new form, Cellulo's acetate, had taken the place of highest cellulo's nitrate for film. Celluloid, born out of billions, was the first plastic. It ushered in a new age of modern products, but it never succeeded in revolutionizing the game of billions.
它在电影的初期是不可或缺的，但它高度危险且易燃。赛璐珞胶片在电影院引发了几起灾难性的致命火灾。到1934年，一种新形式——醋酸纤维素，已经取代了硝酸纤维素用于胶片。赛璐珞，诞生于台球，是第一种塑料。它开启了一个现代产品的新时代，但它从未成功彻底改变台球游戏。
It did, however, revolutionize another table's board. Ping Pong. Before Celluloid was invented, Ping Pong was played with something more closely resembling a golf ball, which, as you can imagine, just didn't have that perfect bounce. Celluloid Ping Pong balls were used for years,
然而，它确实彻底改变了另一张桌子上的游戏。乒乓球。在赛璐珞发明之前，乒乓球是用一种更像高尔夫球的东西打的，你可以想象，它没有那种完美的弹跳。赛璐珞乒乓球用了多年，
but finally got bumped from tournament play in 2013. The reason? They were a little too bouncy. Poor E-Loid, it just can't win. Someday we'll find the perfect home for you, my bouncy friend. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Dan Weissman with Katie Mingle, Sam Greenspan, Avery Truffleman, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks to Dave Bond, who runs the Chicago Billiard Museum, an online museum which has an amazing collection of billiards related documents, data, and images. We'll have a link on our website.
但最终在2013年被踢出了锦标赛。原因是什么？它们太弹了。可怜的赛璐珞，它就是赢不了。总有一天我们会为你找到完美的归宿，我那弹跳的朋友。《99%隐形》本周由丹·韦斯曼制作，凯蒂·明格尔、萨姆·格林斯潘、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼和我罗曼·马尔斯参与。特别感谢芝加哥台球博物馆的经营者戴夫·邦德，这是一个在线博物馆，拥有令人惊叹的台球相关文件、数据和图像收藏。我们会在网站上提供链接。
We are a project of 91.7KALW San Francisco and produced out of the offices of ArcSund. An architecture and interior firm. In beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook. We're on Twitter, Tumblr, Instagram, and Spotify. And you can see that Johnny Apple seed of Billiards Michael Phalan's extremely unsettling neckbeard at 99BI.org. I just want to say one more deal. Just one more. Yes, sir. I ain't listening. Yes, sir, you.
我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在ArcSund的办公室制作。这是一家位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的建筑和室内设计公司。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞这个节目。我们在Twitter、Tumblr、Instagram和Spotify上都有账号。你可以在99BI.org上看到台球界的“约翰尼·苹果籽”迈克尔·费伦那极其令人不安的颈部胡须。我只想再说一件事。就一件事。是的，先生。我没在听。是的，先生，你。
Plastics. Exactly. How do you mean? It's a great future in plastics. Think about it. What do you think about it? Yes, I will. I've said, that's a deal. Radio til P.R.X.
塑料。没错。你是什么意思？塑料的前途一片光明。想想看。你觉得怎么样？是的，我会的。我说过，成交。Radio til P.R.X.
From P.R.X. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自P.R.X。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。